Знайомтеся, це - Андрій Бучко, український далекобійник.
ле він не вписується у стереотипи про представників цієї професії.
Я цю роботу знайшов на парковці під  Міланом.
Він не слухає шансон.
То кума флешка валяється, я її запхав, а там один шансон, я аж бе-е-е...
Вчить в дорозі англійську.
Excuse me miss do you understand Russian?
Має за плечима 20 років служби у Львівській поліції.
Підполковник поліції у відставці.
І з десяток кілограмів контрабандних вареників у машині.
Це не можна везти, тому що поляки забороняють
везти м’ясні і молочні продукти
І навіть веде свій відео-блог.
"Містечко Ла-Рошель!"
Але усе по черзі.
Ну що, поїхали?
Маршрут Андрія сьогодні від Польщі до Франції.
Загалом понад півтори тисячі кілометрів.
Половину дороги він вже проїхав.
Тепер ми на німецькому автобані.
Ми сьогодні веземо столи і ліжка фірми ІКЕА.
Андрій кермує вантажІвкою лише більше року.
У кабіну далекобійника пересів зовсім з іншої роботи.
-Шеф питав, де працював.
Я кажу, трошки далекобійником, але...
малий досвід.
Взагалі, кажу, я юрист і підполковник поліції у відставці.
У львівській поліції Андрій пропрацював 20 років.
Колишні колеги донині не розуміють,
як він пішов на такий кардинальний крок.
Для нього ж це, так би мовити, стиль життя.
Залишатися десь на одному рівні, здобувши його,
це не варіант, тому що
наш світ дуже динамічний, дуже швидко рухається,
розвивається і треба під нього підлаштовуватися.
Андрій змінив не лише професію, а й країну роботи.
Працюю я на польській фірмі, яка обслуговує
практично всі європейські країни.
А живу у Львові.
Просто фірма на кордоні з Україною,
і мені дуже близько і комфортно працювати.
Стажувався Андрій лише тиждень.
Щоправда, старший польський водій, з яким чоловік спершу їздив,
не охоче ділився досвідом.
Я що у нього не питав, він казав: ти маєш знати, ти водій.
Лише через тиждень після стажування Андрій почав
не лише сам їздити, а й навчати інших водіїв.
А згодом завів власний відео-блог,
у якому розповідає новоспеченим далекобійникам про азИ професії.
Молоді водії, які йдуть на роботу,
повинні обов'язково знати це.
Так виглядає мій душ.
Наша тема - це закріплення вантажів.
Бути далекобійником нині набагато легше, ніж раніше,
впевнений Андрій. Вже ніхто не їздить на старих вантажівках,
принаймні в Європі, і не орієнтується за паперовими мапами.
Тепер все в техніці, є навігація, яка нас веде.
Тут є ручні гальма.  Все, вона вже гальмує.
Вже почала...
Настільки тут все автоматизовано, що я, фактично, майже ногами не користуюся.
Набагато безпечнішою стала і сама їзда.
Наприклад,спереду якась перешкода, і я знаю, що я зверну,
а техніка думає, що я їду прямо...
Якщо я не роблю критично рухів, вона сама різко гальмує.
Техніка не лише допомагає, а й наглядає за водієм.
Це тахограф,
Тахограф рахує, скільки годин водій за кермом
і скільки він відпочиває. Для цього кожен водій має свою картку.
Ми маємо право їхати в день
не більше 9 годин.
Щочотири з половиною години ми змушені робити відпочинок
на 45 хвилин.
Максимально за два тижні можна сидіти за кермом
не більше дев'яноста годин.
Бодай найменші відхилення від норми - і тахограф все фіксує.
Порушити ці норми -
про це в Європі навіть ніхто не думає.
тому що дуже великі санкції.
Такі сурові правила убезпечують водіїв від перевтоми і засинання за кермом.
Поліція часто навідується до парковок і зчитує інформацію з тахографів.
В Україні мало хто взагалі їздить з такими картками.
Там якісь магніти вставляють, і воно зупиняє рух тахографа.
Їздити німецькими автобанами Андрію дуже подобається.
Рівна дорога, розмітки, вказівники.
На українських ямах не розженешся.
Тут інфраструктуара самих доріг, автострад дуже розширена.
Тут пікає, і там почало блимати - показує,
що ми вже 4 години 15 хвилин їдемо.
Нам залишилося 15 хвилин їхати.
Але... Перерва, вийшов час, перерва.
У Андрія лише 15 хвилин, щоб знайти вільну парковку.
А це зовсім не просте завдання для насиченого вантажівками
трафіку в Німеччині.
Вечірній час, нічний - неможливо знайти місце.
Ми зараз будемо проїжджати повз паркови
Вже 5-та година, і вже починаються проблеми з парковками.
З першою парковкою не пощастило.
ЗазвичАй Андрій заплановує час на 2-3 невдалі спроби припаркуватися.
Якщо вже на останній нема місця,
тоді вже дуже важко.
Я змушений стати. Це стається між рядами,
на виїзді,  дуже тяжко.
Та сьогодні нам таки пощастило.
Свято наближається,
і всі німці вже додому поїхали.
Зараз будуть пельмені!
Їжею Андрій запасається з дому.
Фастфудів не купує. На німецьких заправках усе страшенно дорого.
Кава - від трьох з половиною євро. Сендвіч - від чотирьох.
У дорогу маю домашні пельмені, морожені,
заморожені.
маю вареники, відбивні -
це все домашнє,
все дружина готує.
Половина усього цього добра перевезено через кордон незаконно.
Бо поляки не дозоляють ввозити м’ясо.
На свій страх і ризик кажу: ні, тільки вареники і тільки з картоплею.
Ціла кухня. Тут є все:
приправи, часник,
олія, соєвий соус,
всі приправи, які хочете.
Запасів вистачає щонайменше на три тижні.
На весь провіант у дорозі Андрій зазвичай витрачає до ста євро в місяць.
Я вже як раз твоїх пельменів поїв.
Поїли - тепер повчитися. Андрій вже рік вивчає англійську.
Виписує невідомі слова з текстів на стікери і клеїть на лобове скло.
Мене поліція навіть зупиняла і питала, що це у вас таке?
Я кажу: "Стікери, вони що, заборонені?"
А під час їзди слухає аудіо-уроки.
Excuse me miss, do you understand Russian?
No Sir, I don’t understand Russian.
Вдома на навчання часу нема.
Там дружина і двоє дітей,
які по три тижні не бачать тата.
Дуже тужимо за своїми рідними.
Хочеться, хочеться додому.
Серед вад роботи і професійні хвороби.
У мене спина хапанула.
Через те, що сидяча робота. У мене зараз
у вигляді масажера - м'ячик.
І мені поставили діагноз - защемлення нерва.
Мені лікар сказав, що крім вправ бажано ходити постійно.
З багатьох причин, по-перше,
По-перше, в Україні не така оплата праці,
ми занємо, що  далеко не так платять.
По-друге, зовсім інші машини.
Тут в Європі нові машини...
Якщо ж машина ламається, то будь-які ремонтні роботи
виконують сервісні служби.
В українських же фірмах навпаки,
весь тягар ремонту лягає на плечі водія, розповідає Андрій.
У мене сусід працює далекобійником на українській фірмі,
Вони їздять зі Львова
до Польщі до німецького кордону.
Це українська фірма.
Минулого тижня він здійснював ремонт двигуна на польській парковці
У польській компанії Андрій почувається набагато більш захищеним.
Вантаж, причеп і сам водій застраховані.
А у разі небезпеки є екстрена кнопка "асистента".
Я от тут зупинюся і не встигну виключити двигун,
як приїде дорожня служба.
Приїдуть запитають, що сталося?
Одразу вогнів понаставляють, щоб ніхто у мене не в'їхав,
в Україні такого нема.
Дратує чоловіка і постійне порушення правил,
яке собі свідомо дозволяють водії в Україні.
Українській водій, якщо він їздить тут, він тут слухняний.
І це дивує тут.  Приїжджають в Україну,
то все, ніхто пасок безпеки не вдягне,
бо це, мовляв, соромно - як же так їхати.
Щоправда, не все так райдужно і в Польщі.
Українським водіям тут платять менше,
ніж своїм, полякам, каже Андрій.
Ба більше, часто обдурюють саме приїжджих водіїв,
бо ті не знають, як себе захистити на чужині.
Поляк поляка не буде кидати, тому що знає, що поляк поскаржиться,
є відповідні контролюючі органи урядові,
потім будуть санкції.
Андрій також пройшов через це і вже змінив одну фірму.
Мене не сильно кинули, але коли я йшов на роботу,
були одні домовленості про зарплату, а коли дійшло
до розрахунку, почалися якісь
вигадані якісь відрахування...
Зарплата далекобійника в Польщі переважно складається зі ставки та добових.
Андрій поки лише отримує добові,
оскільки працює у більш комфортному режимі -
три тижні роботи, три тижні відпочинку.
Зарплата від півтори тисячі євро .
Буває і за дві тисячі.
Самі розумієте, в Україні це нереальна зарплата.
Андрій не шкодує, що змінив професію.
Навпаки - готується до чергового стрибка в житті.
Планує емігрувати з України. Куди - поки не каже.
У мене світогляд дуже розширився, відповідно
у мене є бажання розвиватися в цьому напрямку.
І не сидіти на місці, не чекати, так, як у нас в державі
люди сидять і кажуть: погана держава, погані люди,
нам треба допомогти. Не треба нам допомогти,
треба робити так, щоб ми собі самі допомогли ще й іншим.
Просто треба бажання і не сидіти на місці:
розвиватися в усіх напрямках, випробовувати себе.